aucun pays ne semble épargner en europe
depuis plusieurs mois les prix de
l'énergie flambe selon les données de la
commission de régulation de l'énergie
cela c'est heureux la facture
d'électricité d'un client moyen est
passé de 319 euros par an en août 2007 à
520 euros en août 2021 pourtant
l'ouverture à la concurrence du marché
de l'électricité en 2007 établi dans le
cadre du mécanisme européen de fixation
des prix était censé réguler les tarifs
mais ce mécanisme ne fonctionne pas et
se voit même qualifié d'aberrant par le
ministre de l'économie il faut revoir de
fond en comble le fonctionnement du
marché unique de l'électricité les
français en payent la facture d'une
manière incompréhensible pour eux est
totalement inefficace du point de vue
économique même constat d'échec chez
certaines associations de consommateurs
l'ouverture du marché de l'électricité
est un échec qui s'avère nuisible pour
le bien-être des consommateurs pour ce
professeur d'économie qui s'est confié à
nos confrères de mediapart cet échec
était prévisible parce que ce secteur
n'est pas adaptée à la concurrence de
marché tout ce qui arrive était
prévisible le monde l'électricité n'est
pas adaptée à la concurrence par le
marché les caractéristiques et les
contraintes qui pèsent sur ce marché en
font un monde à part ah parce que
l'électricité les past câble parce que
les réseaux électriques doivent être en
permanence en équilibre sous peine de
s'écrouler parce qu'il faut pouvoir
répondre à tout moment à une demande
instantanée et parfois non prévisibles
l'électricité n'étant pas une
marchandise que l'on peut stocker son
coût est donc déterminé par rapport à la
dernière centrale activée c'est à dire
celle qui va être activé en fonction de
l'offre et de la demande lorsque la
demande augmente les centrales qui
fonctionnent au gaz ou au charbon se
retrouvent sollicités or le prix du gaz
a aussi grimpé ces dernières années
c'est donc le paradoxe que nous vivons
la france a un mix énergétique
complètement décarbonés et pour autant
le prix de marché européen est déterminé
par cette centrale auxquels il faut
ajouter le prix du co2 reste qu'avant
une réforme du marché de l'électricité
prenez notamment par la france et
l'espagne les factures des consommateurs
risquent une fois encore de ressembler à
des montagnes russes